today was the last day of las vegas's
typically biggest convention 40 000
people attended the consumer electronics
show this year that is a 75 percent drop
compared to 2019. originally scheduled
to run right through saturday but it's
ended a day early for pandemic safety
more than a dozen companies including gm
and google had pulled out of in-person
participation
well automakers turned to las vegas to
show how the industry is going green
companies from around the world are
showcasing their electric vehicles at
ces joe moeller was there he's live just
outside the convention center with a
look at it joe
copeland 19 really took a toll on ces
this year but despite that automakers
came here to las vegas to show how the
auto industry is changing
may be down due to covid but companies
are still using it to make headlines
around the world vietnamese automaker
benfast unveiled its electric fleet that
could come to the u.s in the near future
turkish automaker togg pulled back the
curtain on their concept vehicle we are
right at the beginning of this
transformation we are born into that
eugene kurakish came from istanbul he
says this electric car is also showing
off the future of auto technology it's
in that sense more than a car and the
ecosystem itself where we believe the
living rooms and the offices will be
very similar to the living spaces in
these small devices chrysler unveiled
the fully electric airflow concept that
could hit the road by 2025. the company
also announcing a fully electric
portfolio by 2028. general motors
attending the show virtually made waves
online and on social media unveiling its
first electric pickup the 2024 silverado
really overall the pickup truck has got
a ton of technology that we've designed
into it nicole kratz is the chief
engineer of the silverado 400 miles of
range is a huge number and so on the
anxiety around range and whether or not
you'll find a charge station general
motors is building evie grow and other
charge stations gm is taking
reservations online for its release in
mid-2023 general motors is very well
poised to
be competitive in that space
as electric cars take over the show here
just this week it was announced nevada
will get 38 million dollars from the
infrastructure investment and jobs act
now this money will go to expanding the
electric charging network throughout the
state and it will be happening over the
next five years reporting live outside
the convention center this evening joe
mohler live local now